ukraine president volodomir zielinski
had a zoom call with more than 300 u.s
lawmakers pleading for help in getting
nato to declare a no-fly zone over
ukraine nato is refusing saying it could
lead to a full-fledged war in europe
on saturday russia president vladimir
putin warned that could be seen by
moscow as a step into the military
conflict
nato is also refusing to supply ukraine
with fighter jets lawmakers promised to
push u.s president joe biden to make
that happen there are planes available
by nato nations migs that the ukrainians
can fly
they're waiting to be delivered and
apparently the united states
is part of the problem not the solution
zielinski is also asking the u.s to stop
buying russian oil which amounts to
about three to four percent of american
consumption guys like putin they don't
stop
and we got to recognize that the white
house and congress are now pledging
another 10 billion dollars in
humanitarian aid as ukrainians leave
their homeland more than 700 000 people
have been forced to flee the violence
perpetrated by russia by crossing the
border from ukraine to poland
secretary of state blinken visited a
refugee center in poland as that
country's leaders warned putin there
will be consequences for his actions
shelling residential areas
nuclear power plants are war crimes
under international law
which are not subjected to statue of
limitation the u.s state department and
the canadian government are now advising
citizens to leave russia immediately
this came as news emerged that russia
arrested wnba star brittany griner last
month charging her with drug smuggling
for allegedly having vape cartridges
containing hashish oil in her carry-on
luggage this video reportedly showing
the search was released by russia
customs service the problem is that
there is no reliable independent
judiciary in russia
so consequently the expectation of a
fair trial
is not there griner plays for a russian
team during the wnba off-season if
convicted she could spend up to 10 years
in prison her agent says they are
working on getting her back to the u.s
jennifer johnson global news washington